NARRATOR: In 2017, more than 37%
of adults in the U.S.
got a flu shot.
Roughly 80,000 died from
the virus in the US.
But in 1918, there
was no flu shot,
and at least 50 million
people died around the world.
That flu was known
as the Spanish Flu,
and it is the second
deadliest plague in history,
after, well, "the"
Plague in the 1300s.
So how exactly did
a flu virus cause
such massive death and
destruction across the world?
Well it helps to pinpoint
where it started, except we
can't, not with 100% certainty.
It could have been the disease
stricken trenches of World War
I. Or maybe the Shanxi
Province of China, where
the outbreak of a
respiratory disease in 1917
may have actually
been the flu virus.
Or maybe even Camp Funston,
a military base in Kansas
where 48 soldiers died
of flu-like symptoms
right before an outbreak.
What we do know for
sure is that the Spanish
Flu didn't start in Spain.
So then why is it
called the Spanish Flu?
Well, the flu broke out during
World War I. Neither the allied
nor central powers wanted
to admit to additional loss
of life during a conflict
that hinged on who had more
manpower, so all the
nations involved in the war
limited reports of the outbreak.
In the US, some people were even
afraid that reporting the flu
might violate the
"Sedition Act of 1918,"
a law that prohibited
disloyal language
about the government
and any action
against the
prosecution of the war.
But Spain wasn't in World
War I. And since they
had no reason to hide
anything, they reported
their flu-related deaths.
Even the King of Spain,
Alfonso XIII got the disease,
but ultimately survived.
So with the spotlight on Spain,
US and European news outlets
nicknamed it the Spanish Flu.
But the flu was spreading
well outside of Spain.
And with a large scale of
infections going unreported,
no one was prepared
for the deadly pandemic
it would become.
Today, we know the flu
is a highly contagious
viral infection that
spreads to the nose, throat,
and sometimes the lungs.
Symptoms, such as fever, nausea,
aches, and a sore throat,
are all standard.
It's a terrible possibly
fatal disease that confines
the afflicted to bed for days.
But the 1918 Flu was worse.
Dark spots would
appear on the body
before the skin turned
blue from a lack of oxygen
in their blood.
And patients would bleed
from their noses and ears,
as they suffocated on
their own blood and fluids.
In 1918, at Camp Funston,
US army doctor Roy Grist
remarked, "It is only
a matter of a few hours
then until death comes, and it
is simply a struggle for air
until they suffocate.
It is horrible."
The outbreak at Camp Funston
affected more than 1,000
soldiers and killed 47.
But those 1,000 were
part of 1 million
soldiers throughout
Kansas who were all
in contact with one another.
Those soldiers were then sent
overseas in the spring of 1918,
carrying flu microbes that
would spread faster than the war
itself.
In the fall of that same year,
a second wave of flu cases
started spreading across
the US, hitting both
military and civilian centers.
Doctors had never before
seen such a deadly strain
of influenza.
To make matters worse,
knowledge of viruses at the time
was limited, since
microscopes of the day
were not powerful
enough to see them.
People began
blaming the Germans,
claiming they were
spreading poison clouds
or that Bayer, which was
a German owned company,
had infected their aspirin.
As the flu spread in America,
even public health officials
began to lie about
the state of things,
like Philadelphia's public
health director Wilmer Krusen,
who, in September of 1918,
declared, "no concern whatever
is felt," after a
Navy ship from Boston
arrived with
infected passengers.
The next day, two sailors died.
The day after that, 14.
There was little to be done to
stop the spread of the virus.
Doctors had no way to create
a vaccine, antiviral drugs,
or even antibiotics for
secondary infections,
like pneumonia.
Instead, most prevention
efforts focused
on quarantine and
personal hygiene.
Schools, churches, and other
public gathering spaces
were shut down in many cities.
In San Francisco,
they went so far as
to fine people $5 who didn't
wear protective masks,
dubbing them "mask slackers."
And in the end,
after only one year,
the death toll was catastrophic.
To put things in perspective,
more than 16 million people
died in World War I.
The Spanish Flu killed
at least 50 million people.
And some believe the number
may be closer to 100 million.
In the US alone, 675,000
people will die from the flu.
That's more American deaths
than American soldiers
who died in World
War I. It's more
than all the deaths
of American soldiers
in the 20th century combined.
And in October of
1918, 195,000 Americans
died, making it the deadliest
month in US history.
Death was so prevalent
between the war and flu
that life expectancy in
the US dropped by 12 years.
Even Woodrow Wilson was
affected by the Spanish Flu,
having collapsed during the
Versaille Peace Conference
with flu-like symptoms.
The outbreak of Spanish Flu is
what spurred the development
of a vaccine, although
scientists didn't even
isolate the influenza
virus for study
until 1933, 15 years later.
The first flu vaccine
was developed in 1938
and was later given to US
soldiers in World War II.
After the war, it
was finally used
to treat the American public.
[music playing]